[Music]  no no no no no no  no no no no no no no  i can't see you shake my hand  [Music]  my grandmother was right  the boogeyman was real it's over we  can't hurt anyone ever again  no one told you  told me what  somebody in there  [Music]  michael myers  stop you had a knife in your stomach you  and allison  should not have to keep running  evil  dies  tonight  [Music]  i'm not just gonna sit and watch another  innocent person die  if you track michael's victim  that's a straight line to michael's  childhood home  what do we do we fight  let's hunt him down  michael myers is flesh and blood  but a man couldn't have survived that  the fire he kills  the more he transcends  he's the essence of evil  [Music]  [Music]  i'm coming for you michael  [Music]  you